Now, for a long time, I've been in proponent of saying
that it doesn't matter what your language is or what your
platform is. If you follow the memory, you'll find performance problems.
And believe it or not, JavaScripts and HTML5 is no different. That's
why I want to point you at this final option down here
on your Profiles tab called Record Heap Allocations. Now, what this
is going to do? This is actually going to make a log of
all the allocations that occur. While your web application is running. So
I'm going to turn this on and play through the game a little bit
so you can see how the memories reacting to the game
play. [NOISE]
Now of course with that one alien
destroyed, I've now saved the universe. Now, sizing
up this window a little bit actually gives
us a lot of information about what was
allocated during that small time playing. So first off you can
see that we have the types of objects that were allocated
in this column. The distance is not necessarily as important as
you would need it to be right now, so let's ignore that.
Most important is actually this shallow size measure because it actually
shows you the number of bytes allocated to this type of object
so you can see here that the compiled code object is
roughly taking about 2 megabytes or 28% of our overall frame heap.
Expanding compiled code actually gives us locations in executable memory that
tells us what type of data is being allocated. Now, this
is code information, so it's actually not going to be that important
to you unless you're be doing a lot of script injection.
Now, probably a lot more useful to you is actually going
to be a little bit lower in the stack. This object
header you see here. This is actually going to list all of
the class types or object definitions that have been created during our
little playback. Expanding this actually gives us a bunch of pointers into
the memory heap. Clicking on one shows us the retaining tree for
the object. So if we bring this up a little bit. We
can see that there was a module that was called from IG, and
you can see that there was a lot of little global functions
that kind of came into play. So clicking through this list a
little bit more, we can find probably some interesting data. So here
you can see that this one was actually an allocation of a collision
map object. So somewhere while these objects
were falling or debris was occurring The collision
map was called and you can see a lot of the object information listed here.